what was the original release strategy
for laughs and how has it evolved four
laps to the original release was it was
centered around me doing the app at the
time because magic pictures have done
their own app for their web series and I
really like the way they did that so I
tried to kind of use that model and it I
felt like it was good it was a good
little marketing tool but for a web
series it didn't really it really hasn't
kicked off in that sort of Avenue like
that sort of meaning of putting a show
on on a nap I don't think that it really
was as successful as I wanted it to be
and that was something that I learned
you know but um after that it was just
kind of switching to putting everything
on YouTube and that's when 2020
productions contacted me and they wanted
to do distribution on the show so that
was that was nice because I can sort
just hand over the content to them did
you hire an app developer what did you
do it do it yourself no I heard an app
developer yeah they had sort of like a
template version of a panel submit for
you and all that stuff it's actually a
company up in the bay area and they now
they're doing like an app for The New
Yorker and my gamma saw stuff they've
grown a lot and what's the time frame on
building this app with this company or
other news it was like I was like a I
would do my end of like setting up all
the content and how the app would be
structured and then took about a month
and a half I think they submitted it to
apple that it got approved and then
your life it took about couple months
couple months yeah because it was so
template-based it's not like they really
had to go in and do a lot of code work
you know they already had this whole
system setup they really genius idea oh
it's almost like a wordpress site or
something and then they show you where
to put different things and you yeah you
want that look exactly like tumblr
tumblr okay yeah exactly you love
something back to the top oh yeah Adam
I'm hashtag yes hashtag off I want to
get sure that I need to learn it that's
it well do you recommend other web
series creators to explore itunes as a
waiter soon I do i do it you know in
putting your web series as a podcast is
another thing I want to I really want to
try that and then also maybe even going
back to the app but I don't know I'm not
rely solely on that just have it as a
different a different way that you can
get the show you know I was only
focusing on it like this is the only way
you can watch the show and I think that
was a wrong approach well I mean in
hindsight yeah maybe but I mean I'm I
thought was a very novel thing
personally I mean it's you know I'm also
hard on myself so I did I remember it
was marketed as a web series shot on the
iphone for the iphone that was those the
hook the deal and having the app was
just I was just kind of a cool thing as
you tell anybody anybody thought that's
just cool it's and a happy orion an app
you can pull it up then it's
specifically for that I mean the idea of
the time seemed really good but you're
right as really your but you're sort of
bottle linking yourself and choking
yourself into this one Avenue yeah and
when you're trying to get content
anywhere you need to open the floodgates
throw it in any direction you can don't
restrict never ship ever restricted and
thankfully 2020 came on and help me put
the show back out there
yeah that worked out did you have to
hire an aggregator to get it onto iTunes
or does that part about the out that was
part of the whole what the company does
OIC oh yeah they did all the paperwork
and submit it for me and I was like
perfect I don't want to deal with that
and you know if someone's somehow able
to build their own app somewhere or not
you know the woods of Montana everything
you know are they able to just put it on
itunes themselves or do they need an
applicator uh no you can do you can
think it it approved I mean you can
build it right yeah you can build it you
need to get a developer license which is
100 bucks a year and then you would have
to build the app yourself and then
submit it to iTunes and then it's them
approving it or not you need to there's
like a strict guideline to what they'll
what proof know considering half the
apps i've downloaded I'm surprised just
saying so yeah somebody in Montana and
the cabin they probably could yeah I
think so yeah it's all if they have a
broadband connection oh yeah they have
fios out there yeah up by us it's just
funny sick
you